the coronavirus taking center stage as
the race for the white house heats up
president trump and joe biden fighting
over calls for a national mask
mandate take a look
every single american should
be wearing a mask when they're outside
for the next three months at a minimum
every governor should mandate
every governor should mandate mandatory
mask wearing today we saw joe biden
continue to
politicize a pandemic and to show his
appalling lack of respect for the
american people that's what it is
at every turn biden has been
wrong about the virus ignoring the
scientific evidence and putting
left-wing politics before facts and
evidence the biden campaign
doubling down on the mask mandate with
this new campaign ad
joe biden knows we need to listen to
medical experts and take
action now that starts by expanding
testing
calling for masked mandates nationwide
starting immediately
but for the third day in a row joe biden
and kamala harris did not take questions
from the press
at their events and next week all eyes
will be on their virtual convention but
the president will not be taking a back
seat
instead he's going to hit the road
campaigning in four key battleground
states so
we have that to look forward to next
week but let's wrap up
this week tgif greg i cannot resist
asking you about a national mask mandate
because i know this is one of your
favorite things to say
um yes uh i am tired of us
furiously masturbating it's driving me
crazy
let's step back for a minute okay
let's step back for a minute i couldn't
resist trump
this is an amazing comparison trump just
ushered through
an historic middle east peace agreement
that might be nobel prize worthy who
knows i doubt it because it's trump
but he brought arabs and jews together
in a ground-breaking fashion it's pretty
amazing
and we're not leading off with it
instead we have joe
essentially regurgitating what trump's
own
stance was there's no daylight between
them right it's like they took
one of trump's older ideas and they put
it through in an
incoherent language machine uh called
joe biden and then they pretend that
it's news but it's not news what's news
is this middle east peace agreement
but it is it does it it is kind of
striking
something so big and so huge and yet the
candidate
running against trump is basically just
plagiarizing one of his ideas and doing
a terrible job
it's like he wrote the idea out in
crayon
so i want to that's a it's a great point
and
i think i've talked a little bit about
this before like as the incumbent
you get to ha you get to make the news
like you have the bully pulpit
so katie let me ask you about the trump
team's decision yesterday on the rollout
of their historic agreement and then
stepping on it later on by responding
to biden and harris and that then became
the headline
yeah um and you know dana having a
campaign
and moving forward while you're trying
to also govern and deal with foreign
policy is difficult
um you know the biden campaign is
rolling now it's not like the president
can't respond to what is going on when
he's asked by
reporters by giving these press
conferences and that's the difference
the president is out there every single
day answering questions from reporters
but in terms of the policy here um you
know joe biden and kamala harris have
criticized president trump for not
getting on board with a masked mandate
but they keep also saying that we need
to listen to the doctors and the
scientists well
president trump was listening to people
like dr fauci and dr burks early on
who were saying we should not be wearing
masks and now
they've changed their mind on that and
he has listened to them and also said
that it's patriotic to wear a mask but
isn't mandating it by the government
i'm not really clear how you can defund
the police
but then ask for a mandate that has to
be enforced by
who i mean is this going to be a
criminal liability here
are you breaking the law if you don't
wear a mask and who's going to enforce
that the social workers as they have
suggested so
in terms of asking questions of what
they would do differently
would they have shut down the economy or
would they have allowed it to stay open
so people would have
been more infected as the administration
argues i mean they haven't given really
any details about what they would have
done
differently as they throw stones and
criticize the way that the president
handled this
with doctors like fauci and burks
okay but jesse on the point of the fact
that they
um obviously we all know that the mask
thing changed over time
but it's clear that biden and harris
have done a ton of focus groups and like
figured out like what do people want to
hear so they might not really
even want to hear the details they want
to hear apparently that they think
a mask mandate seems to be good you saw
that poll yesterday 75
of all adults think that and then they
broke it down in about 58
of republicans so i i feel like they
were being strategic and rolling that
out first
perhaps they focus group tested it i
mean
i i think people mostly want to follow
the science now
they're trying to outflank the president
with a big government approach think
about this
joe biden is saying if i go sailing or
gardening
or play tennis or take a stroll in my
neighborhood and i'm not wearing a mask
i can be fined and potentially thrown in
prison
i thought we want to keep the jails
empty and i thought we want to recover
from this
economic hit it's the dumbest thing i've
ever heard dana
this thing spreads inside and everybody
knows you keep six feet
this directly contradicts anthony fauci
the entire medical community so
i'm just gonna forget about it the guy
flip-flopped on the
travel ban from china he flip-flopped on
school reopening and he's for extended
lockdowns
joe biden doesn't know what he's talking
about that's number one number two
i looked at these battleground polls
today because you know i'm kind of like
a pollster in my free time
trump's surging in the battleground
polls if you look at the real clear
politics average now
the he's down four points in the
battleground states
that's basically within the margin of
error and you know how they [ __ ] these
polls
i looked at this national poll he's now
down
just seven he was down nine before i
looked at the national poll that came
out i looked at the internals because
this is what i do
all right i looked at how they sampled
it npr
marist they have buying up 11. they
sampled non-white voters at 37 percent
you know how much what
non-white voters turned out in 2016 27
right where'd they get the extra 10
where'd they get that
are they predicting that an extra 10
percent of non-white voters are going to
show up in this election
they can't do that so they're just
making it up out of thin air so
if you combine these juice poles and the
surge
and the sun belt trend going down with
cases and deaths
and a massive q3 number that's going to
come in
while these debates are happening i
think the president is actually in the
driver's seat here
marie how do democrats hope that that's
what republicans think
look i think both sides should run like
they're 10 points down always
because there is some uncertainty with
polls certainly and as as a democrat
i don't believe the polls that have joe
biden up by this much i want us to run
like we're down but the coronavirus is
the
single most important issue to americans
it affects their health
it affects their economy it affects
their families it affects
everything and and donald trump's
numbers across the board and multiple
polls
are really underwater on that issue they
don't think he took it seriously at
first they think he's not listening to
the science he attacks dr fauci
he refuses to wear a mask even though he
talks about mask wearing
so the biden campaign i agree with you
dana has probably looked at a number of
polls and focus groups and
and know that the american people don't
think donald trump has done a good job
responding to this with over 165 000
dead americans
and the cdc saying we're going to have
the worst fall in
history and so that's why they're
focused on this issue i'd love for them
to talk about every issue under the sun
but this is what the american people
care about and they're not happy with
president trump right now it's a good
strategic move
we'll see they'll have to start
answering questions at some point